Dhanbad gina was a former Secret Service
agent NRA TV contributor author of the
brand-new books Spygate the attempted
sabotage of Donald J Trump Dhanbad Gina
joins us now so Dan I hate to think that
any prosecution is politically motivated
but in a country in which a year and
three months is the average sentence for
tax evasion to see a man facing 305
years raises red flags to put a mob Lea
Tucker this case is a disgrace listen I
was a federal agent I don't know Paul
Manafort I don't know what he's guilty
of or not guilty of but I am familiar
with federal investigations and the
tactics used and I can tell you with a
clean conscious eye conscious I have
never ever seen heavy-handed government
tactics like this use for what is
essentially a process crime and
basically a white-collar crime for a guy
with no criminal pedigree at all to
speak of this is unheard of
you know you said at the beginning of
the show justice is supposed to be
even-handed it's supposed to be blind to
Tucker but it appears to be blind only
to Democrats
Paul Matta Ford is guilty of something
he's guilty of helping Donald Trump win
and that's what's bothering the Muller
probe so what's so enough so the point
of criminal punishment is to render
justice to do something proportionate
appropriate to send the statement we
don't accept this kind of behavior
that's why we punish tax evasion and we
should and also to protect the public to
make sure that someone who's a threat to
the rest of us is no longer walking free
in this case the prosecution didn't even
explain how he defrauded the banks did
the banks lose money I don't think they
did they didn't explain how much he
should have paid in federal taxes but
didn't and I don't think there's a
single person in America who feels a
physical threat or even a moral threat
from 69 year old Paul Manafort I mean
they're not even pretending this isn't
political no if they are there's a
really poor job and it really begs the
question Tucker if the federal
government had all the taxpayer assets
that supported thought a Paul Manafort
was such a threat to the Republic why
didn't they warn the Trump team Barack
Obama was the president United States
not the Democrat Party why didn't they
warn the Trump team that this dangerous
threat that
we put in solitary confinement that had
to have the full force of the government
who weaponized against him why didn't
they warn them the answer is because
they didn't believe that I told you Matt
afford his guilty of something he's
guilty of helping Donald Trump win and
by the way
Tucker some of the same process crimes
and suspicious activity
Muller's accused man affordab ironically
enough Democrats accused of the same
thing or people connected to Democrats
seem to have gotten up to this point a
relatively free legal pass even as as a
matter of for appearances would you if
you were robert muller appoint as the
lead prosecutor in a case against Donald
Trump's former campaign manager a
Hillary partisan who went to her victory
party on election night this is a joke
they're not even hiding it can I double
down on it how about this you a Andrew
Weissman yes attended Hillary's party
Jeanne really who is one of his lead
prosecutors in the case represented the
Clinton Foundation Erin's Emily Tucker
another prosecutor in the case who's
friendly with the whole Muller crew
represented think one of the Clinton
guys involved in the destruction of the
blackberries as a lawyer this this is
really happening right now and by the
idea by the way other ones are donors to
Democratic candidates you would think a
guy with Bob Muller's level of
intelligence no one's claiming he's a
dumb guy by the way you would think he
would be smart enough to pick this out
and pick other lawyers and at least
attempt to look nonpartisan for some
reason they don't seem to care yeah or
they're totally lacking in
self-awareness almost everybody in that
world is lacking self-awareness because
they don't know anyone who disagrees
with them which is part of the firm
dampen gee no thank you as always for
the clear explanation